das corona virus ist so nah wie nie die
zahl der infizierten hier in deutschland
die steigt immer weiter
vor allem in nordrhein westfalen und
baden württemberg die lage habe sich
deutlich verschärft sagt dazu
innenminister horst seehofer und ihr
habt euch mit ganz vielen fragen bei uns
schon bereits gemeldet was muss ich über
das virus wissen wie schütze ich mich am
besten aber auch meine familie darum
soll es heute gehen und natürlich könnt
ihr noch weitere fragen stellen postet
sie einfach hier unten wie immer in die
kommentare
und wir versuchen die dann im laufe der
sendung zu beantworten und zwar mit
professor thorsten bauer chefarzt der
lungenklinik heckeshorn guten abend herr
bauer professor bauer hier kommen
natürlich ganz viele fragen zur
gefährdung also wie gefährlich ist
dieses virus und nun hat sich heute der
leiter des robert koch instituts noch
mal dazu geäußert und gesagt dass corona
virus sei tödlicher als die grippe
zumindest nach den aktuellen zahlen
was bedeutet das jetzt ja die solche
vergleiche sind immer schwierig für
menschen wie mich die in der klinik
damit umgehen müssen wir haben über
blicken ja influenza also grippevirus
seit über 20 jahren und wir haben zahlen
von grippetoten die liegen zwischen 5000
und 35.000 in den letzten 20 jahren und
da kann man jetzt schlecht vergleiche
anstellen wie viel tote haben wir zu
erraten
durch das aktuelle corona virus die
meisten infizierten die haben ja einen
leichten krankheitsverlauf
wie groß ist denn überhaupt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass man sich wenn
man sich jetzt an steckt dass man dann
einen schweren verlauf hat das können
wir im moment noch nicht sagen wir
wissen dass die sterblichkeit wenn man
infiziert ist relativ gering ist also
die schätzung waren gestern noch mal auf
einer fortbildungsveranstaltung weil
natürlich auch bei uns nicht alles
bekannt ist die liegen so um die 0,3
prozent sterblichkeit wenn man infiziert
ist aber wer das sein wird das ist immer
ganz schwierig vorherzusagen
trotzdem kommt ihr natürlich in der
kommentarspalte genau dazu kommen die
fragen also wäre es besonders gefährdet
und vor allem auch was was es mit
kindern also kinder
wir scheinen in dieser infektion oder
durch diese infektion nicht besonders
gefährdet zu sein also eher nicht
und wenn man dass sich das
altersspektrum anschaut derjenigen die
gestorben sind zumindestens aus den
daten in china das ist die älteren ab 60
wir vertiefen das thema gleich noch
weiter und wollen jetzt erst mal nach
nordrhein-westfalen schauen
dort gibt es nämlich jetzt 14 neue
infektion also insgesamt sind es jetzt
20 dort im kreis heinsberg und 300
besucher einer karnevalsveranstaltung
sollen dort jetzt in quarantäne
die kappensitzung in gangelt vor knapp
zwei wochen auf ihr war das ehepaar das
mit dem corona virus infiziert ist
rund 300 weitere karnevalisten nahmen
teil und weil sie sich angesteckt haben
könnten müssen sie nun erst mal zu hause
bleiben in quarantäne
auf den strassen heute gespenstische
leere alle schulen im kreis heinsberg
bleiben geschlossen auch die kitas sind
zu eine stadt fast lahmgelegt
die leute versammeln
das infizierte ehepaar wird aktuell im
klinikum düsseldorf behandelt
der zustand des ehemanns ist weiterhin
ernst er leidet an einer schweren
lungenentzündung der erste deutsche fall
mit so einem gravierenden verlauf das
robert koch institut die bundesweit
oberste behörde für
infektionskrankheiten warnt um 15
prozent das hieße also 15 von 100
erkrankten schwer
das ist viel und nach den zahlen die wir
bisher haben muss man davon ausgehen
dass etwa ein bis zwei prozent der
menschen die infiziert werden sogar an
dieser krankheit sterben
und immer neue fälle werden bekannt
jetzt auch der erste in rheinland pfalz
im westpfalzklinikum in kaiserslautern
ist ein junger mann positiv getestet
worden er hatte sich selbst eingeliefert
dieser mann war bis vor kurzem noch im
iran hatte dort kontakt mit menschen die
auffällige symptome am harten fälle wie
diesen ganz genau beobachten und so das
virus so lange und so gut wie möglich
eindämmen
absolut sinnvoll und notwendig betont
der fachmann mit jeden tag oder jede
woche die wir dieses geschehen
die ausbreitung verlangsamen können
steigt die chance dass ein therapeutikum
zur verfügung steht
auch deshalb ist es so wichtig dass sich
die menschen wie die im kreis heinsberg
an die quarantäne regeln halten und die
telefone bei manchen ärzten die stehen
nicht mehr still weil die menschen angst
haben sich angesteckt zu haben
professor bauer was sollen menschen mit
erkältungssymptomen jetzt tun die aber
nicht gereist sind in der letzten zeit
und auch wissen zumindest nicht
wissentlich mit einer infizierten person
kontakt hatten
ja wir haben ja immer noch die
erkältungssaison ich schaue immer ganz
gebannt auf dem wetterbericht wie
schlecht das wetter desto mehr
erkrankungen haben wir einfach von den
atemwegserkrankung und es wird einfach
schwierig die erkrankungen jetzt in
zukunft auseinander zu halten das heißt
das erste ist erstmal ruhe bewahren und
sicherheit ausstrahlen das sind saisonal
möglicherweise saisonale erkrankungen
selbst limitierende erkrankungen die von
alleine wieder weggehen und was mache
ich jetzt also der hals kratzt was tue
ich bleibe ich zu hause und kuriere mich
aus auch schon bei leichten anzeichen
wofür ich mein arzt an und fragt den was
tue ich am besten also ich glaube wenn
der hals kratzt dann sollte man sein
leben so weiterleben wie man jetzt sein
leben auch leben sollte wenn man nicht
aus einem risikogebiet kommt oder wie
sie es gerade beschrieben haben jemanden
kontakt hatte zu jemand der
nachgewiesene infektion hat dann sollte
man das leben erst mal weiter leben denn
die große gefahr die wir jetzt haben in
dieser pandemie situation ist ja dass
das soziale leben nicht mehr
funktioniert
nun laufen hier fragen auch dazu auf was
denn passiert wenn jetzt immer immer
mehr fälle kommen hier fragt sich zum
beispiel ein user drache bei youtube
warum denn die krankenhäuser so marga
wird es hier beschrieben vorbereitet
sind ist das denn überhaupt so also ich
habe ja selbst im krankenhaus
wir hatten heute morgen unsere sitzer
sitzung so ganz mager fand ich uns nicht
vorbereitet das problem ist dass wir
letztendlich die patienten nicht
aussortieren können die keine infektion
mit dem neuen corona virus haben
der test dauert nach wie vor 24 stunden
und wenn dann jemand zu uns kommt und
fragt ob er infiziert ist brauchen wir
24 stunden um die antwort geben zu
können und in diesen 24 stunden muss er
irgendwo hin und die krankenhäuser haben
einfach nicht die räume und die praxen
auch nicht um jetzt zu sagen da legen
sich mal 24 stunden dahin und morgen
reden wir wieder drüber das heißt wenn
wir im krankenhaus über diese infektion
reden da reden wir nicht darüber welches
medikament wir geben können oder ob die
eine infusion brauchen sondern wir reden
darüber wo denn der aufenthaltsort ist
bis wir wissen was es ist
jetzt gibt es ja zum beispiel auch
virologen die sagen es gibt einfach zu
wenig betten wo menschen isoliert werden
können es gäbe nur 60 in deutschland ist
das so gibt es mehr betten kann man die
herstellen in irgendeiner form also das
kommt immer auf den grad der isolation
wenn sie jetzt über schwer tödliche
virus erkrankungen wie ebola oder sowas
reden dann haben wir 60 betten in
deutschland wenn sie über einer
erkrankung wie das aktuelle corona virus
reden also eine erkrankung die deutlich
weniger häufig tödlichen verlauf hat
dann kann man durchaus mehr quarantäne
bitten in kurzer zeit herstellen
gibt es irgendwelche verfahrensregeln
die gerade ausgegeben werden
an zum beispiel hausärzte wie sie sich
dann zu verhaltener haben wenn jetzt
jemand kommt der sagt ich bin eine
kontaktperson ich hatte definitiv mit
dem infizierten kontakt ja die solche
regel versuchen wir gerade zu etablieren
und auch zu kommunizieren das ist zum
beispiel die aufgabe auch des robert
koch institutes und das kommt auch diese
aufgabe
aber letztendlich ist es natürlich auch
den patienten nicht immer leicht klar zu
machen jeder patient fühlt sich krank
schwer krank und wenn man sagt gehen sie
erst mal wieder nach hause und rufen sie
mich an wenn es schlimmer wird dann ist
das nicht unbedingt diese fürsorge die
in deutschland erwartet wird und die
bundesregierung die hat ja auch im
krisenstab gebildet und welche maßnahmen
da jetzt ergriffen werden das hat gabi
handelt fieber husten schnupfen symptome
haben jetzt im winter viele aber ist es
eine grippe oder gar das corona virus
darum sorgen sich viele wollen kein
risiko eingehen für sich selbst und für
andere
wer symptome verspürt soll besser nicht
in apotheken und arztpraxen gehen sagen
experten
telefonisch hilfe suchen sei viel besser
um andere nicht anzustecken
nur eine kleine maßnahme gegen das virus
doch die gesamtaufgabe corona bekämpfung
ist riesig muss von ganz oben
koordiniert werden
die bundesregierung hat einen krisenstab
eingerichtet denn es gebe eine neue lage
für deutschland europa und die welt
wir haben uns dabei darauf geeinigt dass
es wichtig ist dass im zweifel einmal
mehr auf das virus getestet wird als
einmal zu wenig das also es am geld
nicht scheitern darf
die kosten für diese tests werden jetzt
von den krankenkassen übernommen
die bundesländer sollen ihre
pandemiepläne aktualisieren und vor
allem üben
reisende aus risikogebieten sollen ab
sofort so genannte aussteiger karten
ausfüllen damit ansteckungswege sich
nach zeichnen lassen dass wir fordern
den sinn für den fall des auftretens
einer infektion aus einem flugzeug aus
in dem zug zurück verfolgen zu können
wer war mit der infizierten person in
diesem flugzeug stoppen lässt sich das
virus wohl kaum noch aber die
ausbreitung verlangsamen bremsen je mehr
zeit vergeht desto besser wird das virus
erforscht desto besser kann es bekämpft
werden und zu denen alle maßnahmen vor
allem dem einen ziel infektionsketten
unterbrechen
also das waren jetzt die pläne der
bundesregierung aber viele von euch
fragen sich vor allem die sie sich
selbst schützen können und wir gucken
jetzt mal hier in die kommentare rein da
ist nämlich dazu schon einiges
aufgelaufen zum beispiel von jenny die
fragt ganz konkret nach
großveranstaltungen wie fußballspielen
oder geländes fragt auch nach so etwas
wie chorprobe oder auch
theateraufführungen professor bauer da
würde ich mal sie fragen soll man sowas
meiden in zukunft ja jetzt haben sie
drei verschiedene veranstaltungen
genannt wobei ich den fußball jetzt beim
ausnehmen würde der findet nun mal
einfach an der frischen luft statt und
sowie virus lasten in frischer luft
sehen eigentlich drüben nicht niedriger
war der korb wo das dürfte die höchste
belastung sein weil natürlich atemwege
infiziert sind und sie haben eine ruhe
virus last also das muss jeder
letztendlich für sich selbst entscheiden
ist jemand in der chorprobe infiziert
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit relativ hoch
dass er diese infektion weitergeht
da passt ganz gut und die frage von
johannes dazu der fragt sich wie wird
denn das virus genau übertragen nur
durch tröpfchen und das passiert im chor
abzulenken
ja ja es wird was es wird bringen muss
sich auf diese tröpfcheninfektionen
hinauslaufen das virus verbreitet sich
eben oberen atemwegs trakt das heißt im
mund und im rachen und das kann sich
danach eben auch in der lunge verbreiten
und das sind wahrscheinlich die
erkrankungen die dann mit schweren
verläufen hergeben wir haben jetzt
gerade schon über menschenansammlung
größere veranstaltungen gesprochen
müssen da denn jetzt zum beispiel ältere
menschen was anderes beachten als vitale
jüngere menschen die kern gesund sind
das muss im ältere menschen immer weil
sie einfach eben mehr wie wir sagen
komorbiditäten haben das ist einfach das
bringt das alter nummern und mit sich da
hat
mehr am herzen mehr an der lunge und
wenn man eine schwere erkrankung bekommt
und es gibt schwere verläufe ist wie ich
gar nicht in abrede stellen
dann hat man einfach ich sechs mal so
lockt die schlechteren karten
weil ein organ wie eine lunge eben
leichter versagen kann wenn es vor
geschädigt ist und noch mal zum
verhalten kommt hier eine frage bei
facebook von rainer der ist
wochenendpendler fährt also vielen
überfüllten zügen und fragt sich jetzt
ob er mehr home office machen soll das
darf er nämlich von seinem arbeitgeber
aus was raten sie ja jetzt sind wir
wieder bei der auf erhaltung der
aufrechterhaltung der infrastruktur home
office ist natürlich eine gute
alternative wenn es von zuhause genau so
gut klappte wie wie wenn man zur arbeit
geht
ich arbeite jetzt im krankenhaus also
für mich kommt es nicht in frage
wir kommen sehr sehr viele fragen zum
virus selbst und zum verlauf die würde
ich gerne mal mit ihnen nacheinander
durch geben hier kommt eine von habib
veröff bei youtube wie lange hat man das
culinary corona virus wenn man sich
ansteckt
wir glauben im moment das man circa 14
tage ansteckend ist ansteckend ist aber
auch selber dann symptome hat oder die
symptome werden wahrscheinlich früher
enden dass man gestern etwas diskutiert
man würde sagen so ungefähr acht tage
symptome aber 14 tage ist man noch virus
träger ob man dann auch noch ansteckend
ist in der zeit das wissen im moment
noch genau dass wir auch die nächste
frage von dorota gewesen ob man denn
danach dann immun ist also das wäre dann
die anschließende kann man damit rechnen
oder gibt es hinweise darauf dass das
anders sein könnte ja die immunität des
des corona virus lässt wahrscheinlich
eine lebenslange immunität nicht zu ich
würde mal sagen man ist sicherlich
kurzfristig immun und sagen wir mal für
die immunität ist kurzfristig eine zahl
von monaten
aber ob sie damit im nächsten jahr noch
punkten können mit ihrer immunität das
würde ich heute mal nicht beschweren
hier kommt außerdem bei youtube eine
frage von jan der möchte gerne wissen
gibt es fälle von corona infizierten die
gar keine symptome zeigen ja sehr gut
also nicht gut den umständen
entsprechend gut untersucht ihr habt ja
diese rückkehrer aus china die dann in
germersheim glaube ich in der kaserne
pensioniert wurden zehn davon waren
krank die gegen die in die uniklinik und
die anderen haben sich bereit erklärt
abstriche machen zu lassen
und da waren zwei patienten darunter die
virus positiv waren aber nicht krank und
das ist so ungefähr die zahl die man
glaubt also ungefähr bei 1 1 bis 2
prozent der patienten sind überträger
aber selbst nicht krank
hier kommt außerdem noch eine frage zu
den tests die jetzt durchgeführt werden
auch zu diesem schnelltest wie die
funktionieren können sie das erklären
naja ich versuch's mal also das sind
sind sogenannte pcr polymerase chain
reaction
das heißt man versucht bestimmte
aminosäure sequenzen die für das virus
typisch sind zu applizieren also
herzustellen und damit das virus zu
nachzuweisen das ist quasi wie im tatort
der genetische fingerabdruck und dazu
braucht es eben diese sogenannten
amplifikation verfahren die pcs und das
ist ein standardverfahren für aminosäure
sequenzen und kann bei allen bakterien
oder eben auch beim genetischen
fingerabdruck des täters verwendet
werden wir gehen noch einmal kurz zurück
zum thema wie verhalte ich mich hier
kommen jetzt nämlich doch auch noch ein
paar fragen zum thema reisen und zwar
danach tom fragt hier zum beispiel
geschäftlich soll er für eine woche nach
spanien fliegen nach madrid ob man seine
reise antreten sollte und jemand anderes
bei youtube fragt eine reise nach
thailand
was sagen sie dazu ja das werde ich auch
im bekanntenkreis häufig gefragt also
viermal auf die erste frage antworten
madrid würde ich mir noch nicht entgehen
lassen
endlich ist die infektions lage nicht so
dass die infektionen sage ich mal in
madrid eine andere
wer also jetzt in hamburg oder in berlin
wäre und in thailand ist im moment eben
auch die situation relativ ruhig wobei
man sagen muss dass wahrscheinlich das
feedback das gesundheitssystem in
thailand jetzt nicht so engmaschig ein
feedback gibt wie zum beispiel das was
sie gerade gesagt haben wie viele fälle
haben wir da und da aber letztendlich
ist es eine erkrankung die sie in
wenigen wochen und wenigen monaten
überall auf der welt bekommen können
hier möchte benedikt bei youtube gerne
wissen kann das virus denn notieren
diese frage kommt relativ häufig also es
ist der wesentliche unterschied zu der
in flames also zum grippevirus dieses
virus mutiert sehr wenig das heißt wenn
jetzt dieser durchlauf durch ist das ist
ja im prinzip von einer fledermaus dann
auf den menschen übertragen worden in
welcher form auch immer und dann eben
von mensch zu mensch übertragen worden
und dieses virus wird jetzt seinen weg
um die welt machen da werden wir sowie
lothar wieler das gesagt hat wir können
das maximal verzögern
aber wir können es nicht verhindern aber
diese art der viren mutiert relativ
langsam aber es wird eine neue
kombination geben die die menschheit
noch nicht kennt das ist so alle zehn
jahre der fall
eine weitere frage die hier auch recht
häufig kommt dass die nach einem
heilmittel oder einem impfstoff wie
sieht denn da stand da jetzt
mittlerweile aus also hier muss man
sagen heilmittel ist bei viren schwierig
es gibt 22 viruserkrankungen die gut
heilbar oder steuerbar sind durch
antivirale medikamente dass die
hepatitis also die leber in szene und
das ist dass die infektion mit dem
hiv-virus ansonsten sind virus
medikamente häufig nicht gut wirksam das
was wirksam ist ist unser immunsystem
und das faszinierende ist ja auch nicht
wann werden wir krank sondern warum
werden wenn ich jeden tag krank und das
ist die leistung unseres immunsystems
und deshalb ist die impfung entscheidend
bei der impfung ist es so sie müssen
einen impfstoff entwickeln wir müssen
belegen dass er wirkt und sie müssen die
in den großen mengen herstellen
können ja sie wollen ja in deutschland
auch schnell mal 20 30 millionen
impfdosen haben wenn sie einen wirksamen
impfstoff haben das dauert seine zeit
ich habe hier noch einige fragen von
euch wirklich zum thema gefährdung ich
stelle sie jetzt einfach mal obwohl wir
auf ein bisschen was schon eingegangen
sind und zwar möchte hier julia wissen
sie seiner 38 schwangerschaftswoche wie
gefährlich ist das corona wäre es für
mich und nach der entbindung für das
neugeborene sollte ich das öffentliche
leben meiden
also 38 schwangerschaftswoche da fehlt
ja nicht mehr viel bis zur geburt also
die zwei worden würde ich jetzt mal
vielleicht daneben mich nicht in
unbedingt in einer infektion situation
begeben
für schwangere besteht kein höheres
infektionsrisiko als für nicht
schwangere frauen und für neugeborene
wissen wir dass mich oder ich kann sagt
mal ehrlich weiß ich es nicht
und miriam möchte hier auch nochmal eine
frage in die richtung stellen sie ist
asthmatiker in muss sie sich in
irgendeiner form anders verhalten
asthmatiker gehören zu den comer bieten
patienten das heißt sie haben bereits
eine lungenerkrankung und bei
asthmatikern wissen wir dass wenn sie
virus infekte der lunge bekommen dass
asthma schon mal ausgelöst werden kann
deshalb ist es gerade für asthmatiker
wichtig die medikamente regelmäßig
einzunehmen
ansonsten gelten dieselben empfehlungen
für den schutz
jetzt wird das thema mundschutz hier
natürlich auch bei uns immer wieder
angesprochen und wir haben schon gelernt
in den letzten tagen so richtig hilft
das nicht wenn man sich schützen will
auf der anderen seite könnte man darüber
doch auch sagen na ja aber wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel träger bin und ich
weiß es noch ganz dann schützt sich doch
zumindest mein umfeld oder sind das
mundschutz sind freundlich naja also so
umfunktioniert dass es ist ja so man
kennt ja auch schon vor zehn jahren
diese bilder aus asiatischen städten wo
die die menschen mundschutz tragen und
was wir immer denken ist dass sie sich
vor der bevölkerung schützen wollen aber
die asiatische tradition gibt es eben
her dass man selbst wenn man erkrankt
ist versucht die anderen zu schützen und
darf funktioniert der mundschutz auch
also das ist ja eine tröpfcheninfektion
ich muss jemanden an husten
und wenn ich eine mechanische barriere
davor habe dann funktioniert das schon
so und sie haben das immunsystem schon
angesprochen und hier kommt auch eine
frage dazu von agris und der möchte
wissen kann ich denn mein immunsystem in
irgendeiner form jetzt stärken damit ich
da besser dastehe im kampf gegen das
corona virus also dass sie mein system
stärken können wir ärzte nicht das wird
immer wieder behauptet wenn man sage ich
mal die vorabendsendung sieht und dann
die werbeblöcke da gibt es viel was das
immunsystem stärkt nichts davon ist
belegt deshalb es gibt keine wirkliche
stärkung des immunsystems also er fragt
hier ganz explizit nach obst und gemüse
essen immer gut immer gut ok immer gut
also merken wir uns obst und gemüse
essen natürlich auch händewaschen nicht
vergessen darüber haben wir jetzt gar
nicht gesprochen aber ich glaube das ist
jetzt auch schon gemeinhin bekannt dass
das eine sehr sehr gute idee gerade ist
und eine der wichtigsten sachen
eigentlich und professor bauer ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich dass sie sich
heute die zeit genommen haben für uns
und für die vielen fragen her und ich
bedanke mich natürlich auch bei euch
fürs zuschauen
für die vielen fragen für die kommentare
und hoffe wir konnten viel davon klären